but sup guys welcome to an episode of IJ
likes now this is gonna be a special one
and it's dedicated to breaking bad so
pretty much everything I'm about to talk
about it has to do in some way with
breaking bad there will be no spoilers
if you've never seen it you guys know
finale was this weekend and I'm on the
west coast so the East Coast sometimes
there's things like really shady streams
that you can get so I ended up watching
one of those I'm like sitting on my
computer who's just freaking out because
every time the stream would drop I would
I misses some critical part of the
episode but I couldn't wait until 9
o'clock because I wanted to just see it
I wanted to see it I couldn't I just
couldn't wait to be honest with you the
finale was amazing and I'm so glad they
tied up every little thing that the
audience wanted to have it tied up so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below if you watched it if you
didn't watch it well then we have
nothing to talk about
but I did see on Amazon they're doing
pre-orders for the entire set season and
it's in like this cute little barrel I
was gonna buy one for myself but I
decided that I've seen them all so I'd
rather buy one for you guys so I'm gonna
do a giveaway I just don't know how that
giveaway is gonna happen so stay tuned
towards the end of the video which will
give me enough time to figure out how
I'm gonna do the giveaway first up on IG
likes is some amazing Breaking Bad
videos that have been my absolute
favorites this first one is the Breaking
Bad of middle school musical by
rhettandlink want to take my life
savings buy an RV and make candy in the
desert sounds like an awesome decision
your shiny new car you've lost her soul
Walt you are a disgrace even along the
lines of musical numbers this is a
Taylor Swift parody of we are never ever
ever getting back together
they did such a good job including
pretty much every character from the
show into this music video and just so
many inside jokes so props you guys this
was just absolutely amazing
this next one speechless it's every
little instance where Jesse Pinkman gets
injured or hurt or something terrible
happens to him
in your days
now this video is a must watch it's an
interview with a woman who owns the
actual house that the entire show pretty
much takes place in at Walter White's
house in Albuquerque this is her house
she lives here it is her home we have a
fan of the the People fan of the show oh
yeah and it's been it's really been a
hell of an experience and having all
these people here and meeting people
from all over the world next up in
gaming and tech the only thing that has
been trending on Twitter other than
Breaking Bad is GTA now finally this
week Grand Theft Auto online launches
and they've already use the statement
saying don't plan on actually being able
to get on to our servers because they're
probably gonna fail to make sense
considering this game made over a
billion dollars in three days so much
funny make sure you guys check out a
bunch of my GTA videos on my gaming
channel youtube.com slash ijustinegaming
also this past week Taco Bell announced
they're doing a promotion with
Playstation 4 they're giving away a
PlayStation 4 every 15 minutes you guys
do the math because I don't really yeah
I'm not gonna do it for you I got a
chance to go up and visit the Taco Bell
headquarters where we went to their Test
Kitchen and they gave us so much food it
was kind of overwhelming whatever reason
you miss birth and you were thinking
about lunch this is what you do to get
your breakfast in your lunch of the same
exact eyes
good luck to anybody who enters to win
the PlayStation 4 I think all you have
to do is go to Taco Bell and buy one of
the big box meals and you're injured and
I love to talk about God I can go for a
quesadilla right now this weekend I
choose book club I downloaded Dexter's
final cut by Jeff Lindsey I don't know
how I'm gonna be able to handle all of
my favorite TV shows ending as always if
you guys want to get your free book you
can go to audible.com slash iJustine
link is in the description for those of
you who just like to click let me know
the book you guys download and also
leave me some suggestions on what I
should download next week if I pick your
suggestion I'll give you a little
comment here or something this episode
would not be complete without a fashion
and style segment but this fashion and
style is brought to you obviously by
Breaking Bad I found all of these
amazing t-shirts this website had over
95 Breaking Bad t-shirts and every
single one of them was just speechless
now the teachers weren't enough we've
also got some Breaking Bad jewelry
thank you guys for hanging out with me
on this AJ likes breaking bad episode I
have finally decided what to do for the
giveaway I'm gonna post this video on
Facebook so all you have to do is go to
Facebook like my page like the status
that this video is on and leave me a
comment I'll let you guys know on
Facebook who wins this amazing Breaking
Bad full DVD set I mean it's so awesome
like it just that's it guys see you
later